là où ça bouge comme ce soir au zénith
de rouen une fois n'est pas coutume pour
vous annoncer un spectacle qui aura lieu
au zénith de caen le 3 avril à 18 heures
avec le retour des ports ou qui sont là
tout de suite de génériques
combien de temps vous avez des numéros
d'invités avec deux chansons déjà alors
le roi la semaine quasiment leur chasse
a été oui oui semaine carrément et
on a été 48 moi je crois au top le lion
était numéro trois au top 50
et il y avait le top albums à l'époque
où on a été numéro trois aussi la
mémoire pascal perri royal boch tous la
mémoire différentes mers
et encore à toi je te jure croyait plus
car ce n'était pas calculé comme ça
personne n'y croyait nous les premiers
d'ailleurs c'est le public qui nous a
consacré le public en premier et après
on a eu cette chance effectivement
d'avoir deux victoires de la musique
donc c'est vrai que là en plus le métier
qui nous qui nous disaient merci quelque
part enfin qui reconnaissait notre au
talent qu'on peut le dire moi je le dis
voilà mal à le dire mais bon au mieux
notre talent et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
on pouvait même pas s'imaginer le
qu'aujourd'hui on sera là en train de
parler mon jacques parce qu'on se
connaît depuis longtemps car les villes
vous a suivi mais à mon retour
le nouveau disque c'était ton preneur de
son qui nous a dit tout à l'heure qu'il
était tout petit qu'il était ravi d'être
là aujourd'hui par exemple c'est notre
ami le ramène qui nous a fait l'amitié
de nous rejoindre pour nos trois
chansons voilà donc laurent on s'était
croisés à l'époque parce que si on le
ramène de native on était les pogos on
était un peu on surfait elle et nous sur
le sur les sommets
et voilà à l'époque on n'a pas trop le
temps de faire connaissance mais on
s'est rattrapé depuis
mais voilà comme l'aura été sur la
tournée elle nous a fait le plaisir de
de nous rejoindre et de participer à nos
un autre passage pas j'ai conscience que
vraiment native a été précurseur de
quelque chose en france
après pour vous évidemment un groupe
vocaux en france ils sont jeunes a pas
vraiment de successeur même si des tas
de chorales se sont développées même si
nos chansons sont reprises dans les
écoles mais c'est vrai que la culture
turque
l'album de camille capelle la non mais
même à l'époque il y avait quand même
des groupes mais c'était plus des
chapelles donc nous on a quand même
rendu la capella on va dire à plus
populaires à travers le chat
om aurait si vous voulez retrouver les
pogos c'est le 3 avril au zénith de caen
à 18 heures
à la notable le redoutable le genre soit
merci beaucoup aux propos qu'il faut
donc partie de la tournée top 50 avec
les vertes alphaville savez
une pâture elle car une loeb ou encore
partenaire particulier bref du beau
monde mais j'entends sabine daniel cette
fois ci qui ne fait pas de bêtises qu'on
appelle d'hérouville pour deux impôts
nous sommes à la comédie de caen
hérouville car nous allons tout à
l'heure discuter avec catherine hiégel
et didier bezace pour parler de retour
au désert de bernard-marie koltès qui
est donc donné à la comédie de caen ce
soir et demain
mais avant je voulais juste vous
préciser jacques que l'on connaît les
derniers noms de jazz sous les pommiers
et les nouveaux derniers invités sont
d'âge malay le grand bluesman viendra
enflammer coutances à 73 ans il encore
la pêche
dee dee bridgwater fera son retour en
normandie
sarah mackenzie la pianiste australienne
à la voix d'or chantera bien sure we
could be lovers il y aura aussi chris
potter quartet guillem les le quintette
erik truffaz zh bref tout le programme
de la 35e édition de jazz sous les
pommiers c'est sur le site jazz sous les
pommiers points comme on se retrouve
demain avec catherine hiégel et didier
bezace qui nous parleront de retour au
désert de koltès qu'il joue ce soir et
demain à la comédie de caen allait à
demain